we are now nearing the end thankfully of
the emergency situation you happy about
that
police excessive behavior the people
believe that the country's in good hands
for some years the government of Hungary
has been one of the bad boys of Europe
especially when it comes to issues about
the rule of law but in March Prime
Minister Orban secured an open-ended
right to rule by decree in order he said
to fight the corona virus pandemic and
now the outcry across Europe is much
louder my guest this week from Budapest
is balázs hit Vega a Hungarian MEP from
the ruling Fidesz party is the
government being honest about its
motives or is its new law just the
latest move to cement authoritarian rule
[Music]
well Ashley Twiggy welcome to Kazakhstan
yes hello good morning why did your
Prime Minister need an emergency law to
deal with a pandemic everyone else
relies on testing tracing quarantines
lock downs but you had to have a law
that goes after people who criticize the
authorities why well very simply
everything has been done according to
the Hungarian Constitution the
government when the pandemic when the
virus situation began declared a state
of danger it can do it for two weeks and
following the two weeks is the Hungarian
Parliament that has the right to decide
whether to prolong this or not and
that's what's happened the Hungarian
Parliament decided to prolong the
situation as long as the pandemic was
there we are now nearing the end
thankfully of the emergency situation it
has been taken take hold quite well it
seems thanks God and thanks to the good
efforts of the government so we're
coming to the end of this state of
emergency of state of danger very
similar things and very similar special
orders of special decisions have been
made across the European Union for that
matter to do but they haven't they
haven't cracked down on people who
criticize the authorities the way you
have this virus has in effect just given
your government the opportunity for
grabbing more power and cracking down on
opposition hasn't it you didn't need
these powers at all you didn't need
these powers at all not at all that's
far from the truth in fact the Hungarian
government Fidesz Christian Democratic
coalition has a two-thirds majority in
the Hungarian Parliament why would we
have to do anything to increase our
power we have an extraordinarily strong
political mandate thanks to the
Hungarian population and thanks to the
results of the last elections we didn't
crack down or anything we just had to
deal with a situation that was
extraordinary in every sense of the word
mr. bellusci
I'm thankful that you say you didn't
crack down but the police said last week
Hungarian police said last week they'd
opened nearly 90 cases of scare
mongering against citizens since your
emergency law took effect let's be
honest this is nothing but a concerted
attempt to stamp out criticism of the
government and its policies isn't it it
has nothing to do with criticism of the
government or criticism of political
issues
quite simply during a state of danger
and during the state of a pandemic that
has been as dangerous as this one
control has to be accomplished but
according to the law and according to
the Constitution rule of law works in
Hungary very well and if there was no
ground to to go after anybody for for
scare mongering or any other thing then
the case was closed according to the law
so they're actually the special order
and the special situation has shown that
it was under control and it was
according again to the Constitution your
law makes clear that it's not just going
after people who put out false facts
you're even going after people who
according to this law section 337
paragraph 1 miss represent true facts in
other words if the government doesn't
like the way people interpret their
facts they could face up to five years
imprisonment couldn't they and that's
free speech or the Aryan style it's not
about this no no it's not it's not it
has nothing to do with political opinion
it has nothing to do with the free
speech or a Liberty of thought it has to
do with spreading fake information false
information that have nothing to do with
the facts under a situation during a
situation where there is increased
danger of the population because of a
pandemic you have to make sure that only
reality and real facts are transmitted
only your reality news only your reality
only the reality that the government
sees two cases were brought to the
attention of the Hungarian Civil
Liberties Union which condemned the
detention of two Facebook users who
criticized the government and the
confiscation of their communication
devices as
obviously excessive you happy about that
police excessive behavior there was no
police excessive behavior these people
the two people that you mentioned will
let free within some hours within the
same day after their case was looked at
let me tell you this in Germany over the
past few months almost forty cases were
reported where police went after people
because of comments because of posts on
Facebook or other social media outlets
there is an incredibly there is an
extraordinary situation and on top of it
on social media all kinds of fake news
are transmitted and authorities across
the European Union or across the whole
world I might say are trying to find a
way to deal with that so that public
order is is maintained and also the
rights of everybody are respected mr.
Bosch you said the two people were
released in the case of one of them and
just kasinski in the north of the
country the case was dropped but not
before police had uploaded a video on
the Internet of him being escorted from
his home and into a police car that's
trial by internet this is nothing more
than thuggish intimidation by your
police isn't it and it was condemned by
the Hungarian Civil Liberties Committee
as having a chilling effect on many
ordinary social media users that's
exactly what it's meant to do isn't it
to have this chilling effect scare the
population into silence and eradicate
criticism not not at all in fact if you
look at the Hungarian public discourse
if you look at Hungarian politics if you
look at the Parliament we have one of
the most vibrant debates here across the
whole European Union with a whole range
of various opinions and different points
of views are presented and can be
presented that's right that way there's
no intimidation at all those those
commentaries have nothing to do with
reality I don't think well you may not
like the accusations against your
country and we'll we'll look at some of
them in detail but your denials
Hungary was undertaking any
anti-democratic moves haven't exactly
been believed have they and particularly
now we have the Reporters Without
Borders organization saying that you
passed an Orwellian law that introduces
a full-blown information police state in
the heart of Europe I give you a couple
of examples which were criticized by the
Hungarian Civil Liberties Union and you
reject them out of hand you've said in
the past the accusations against Hungary
are false Hungary has a free and
independent world of justice science and
education
I wonder who on earth did you think was
going to believe you when you said these
things when the evidence - the country
is so overwhelming I don't think the
evidence is overwhelming at all contra
against the Hungarian government in fact
if you look at the results of a series
of elections in Hungary free elections
democratic elections defeatist
government has won one after the other
because the people believe that the
country is in good hands the people
believe the majority of people believe
that the government is doing a good job
and they would like it to continue to do
a good job also there are debates at
European level there are debates in the
European Parliament there are debates
amongst heads of state and government
and your spokesman post them which
answer whose opinion matters but there
are debates political debates by the way
the law the special though about the
coronavirus in Hungary that was in the
in the middle of so much criticism some
weeks ago was looked at in detail by the
European Commission which is the
guardian of the treaties of how the
European Union works and they found that
in no way did it go against any
democratic norm or European law and they
said that repeatedly so there is a
difference between a political campaign
there is a difference between pressure
groups saying you know what they would
like to say because their ideology their
values are different from the Fidesz
government and and and the difference
between that and the fact and the real
look at facts and reality and the real
record of the government well let's look
at what some of your people think about
that
to one survey between March the 3rd and
March the 10th by the friedrich ebert
foundation 50% half of your citizens now
think that conditions for democracy and
press freedom have worsened in Hungary
this was before your emergency law and
only 17% 1/7 thought that there'd been
any progress in that field in those
fields doesn't say much for your
democratic credentials does it
I don't think so there are several
surveys in fact and they able to stiffen
is a well-known social democratic
foundation it's very nice no problem
with it you're saying it's slanted I use
do other surveys
you're saying it's lying that time I
just said the fact I'm just I just said
the fact that it's a social democratic
foundation in its value system and
perhaps that has an influence
sometimes on how they interpret findings
but I'm not questioning their finding
I'm just saying that there are several
surveys but the most important survey of
course is always in a democracy
elections parties go for elections the
Fidesz government has been reelected
three times with an overwhelming
majority and that tells you something I
think about the real record of the
government and the real situation
Hungary that is worth looking at I think
I want to come on to the topic of
elections and how you manage them and
how you've changed various laws relating
to the elections since since you came to
power but let's just look at the press
you maintain that Hungary has a diverse
press and free speech and criticism of
the government is allowed the fact is
your government does go around smearing
the few independent journalists in your
country who are left as Hungary haters
foreign agents or traitors doesn't it
and it does use its enormous financial
resources to try and put independent
journalists out of business as the joint
international press freedom mission to
Hungary reported last year state
advertising has been weaponized to fund
pro-government media and staff
independent outlets did you seriously
think mr. hid vaguely that people didn't
notice what was going on well they are
drawing the wrong conclusions obviously
if they say
things in fact political debate as I
said before and public discourse in
general is one of the freest in the
European Union it's more taboo free than
in many other places in Western Europe
or elsewhere in the European Union
topics are freely discussed there is
more of a balance of media if you look
at the media structure and if you look
at the value system behind media's or
what kind of ideology they they prefer
there there is a big variety in Hungary
perhaps more of a variety than in other
places that these organizations are are
used to state funding and advertising as
much as this estate or as much as it is
companies is spread across the board
so I don't think there is any you say
that in balance in the Hungarian
situation at all you say that but all
regional daily newspapers are now under
government control aren't they and you
call that a Free Press there's only one
independent political daily newspaper
left Knepp Chava and that's in Budapest
with a circulation of just 20,000 by
contrast the network of regional daily
papers controlled by the government
reaches 200,000 people one single
independent talk radio station whose
audience is restricted to be the pest
and you call that a fair balance well
that's that's not the whole of the
picture there are other regional
newspapers and there's not only print
media obviously and there's not only
traditional radio frequencies there is
now also the Internet and if you look at
for example internet-based
news portals if you look at political
weekly newspapers both printed and
online if you look at online radio
stations there is a balance here and
there are in fact there are in fact if
you look at the online world a heavy
bias or heavy advantage towards the
critical media towards the government
Freedom House accused your government of
dropping any pretence of respecting
democratic institutions taking over much
of the media it said and harrassing
critical society organization Hungary's
decline it added has been the
precipitous ever tracked in its survey
of nations in transit that's not much to
be proud of is it well
Freedom House once was an organization
that that I respected I don't think
their analyses over the past couple of
years have been trustworthy or based on
facts in fact let me pose the question
to you if it were true just for a sake
of the argument if it were true there
was that there was so little freedom or
no freedom in the media or in the public
discourse in Hungary then why and how
could we have such lively debates about
political issues in Hungary about social
issues in Hungary about the European
Union and and then a whole range of
other issues in Hungary then it would be
ample impossible to have those debates
there is now more of a need for prepress
in Hungary than ever before isn't there
especially since corruption has
blossomed under your party's rule in
September 2019 Europe's anti-fraud
office Olaf
warned that when it came to
misappropriation of EU funds Hungary was
the worst performing state in the EU
nearly four percent of EU provided money
was misused and should have been
returned during the 2014 to 2018
reporting period that's pretty shameful
isn't it they were looking at in fact or
Olaf situations and projects that go
back to the time before the Fidesz
government the European Parliament was
just voting by the way this past week
about about some of those reports and
the functioning of of Olaf and other
agencies those go back to as far as 2005
2006 and 7 those were years before the
Fidesz government began to function now
in a more general sense but 2014 to 2018
we've had time to give the money
boundaries there is there is corruption
everywhere obviously in the EU and they
have to be looked into if you look at
the way for example investigations by
the public prosecutors or by police are
initiated based on recommendations by
Olaf this European Union agency Hungary
is amongst the best in fact performers
of
the the percentage of how many Luke's
cases are looked into following all of
things there are similar cases with
other European Union member states I
reject the opinion that there would be
more corruption or significantly more
corruption in Hungary than in an average
situation in in the region or in in the
European Union well it must be a comfort
for you and other members of your party
that Fidesz now enjoys an effective
stranglehold over prosecutors offices
the Constitutional Court the Curia the
highest court of appeal and the Audit
Office grand slam to your party total
total control of the organs of just all
that is not the case at all that is not
the case at all that is an
often-repeated political attack by a
frustrated Hungarian opposition that
hasn't been able to win elections for a
good number of national elections now
they are frustrated they have been
unsuccessful but that doesn't make true
there those accusations that you've just
repeated well after mr. Albin came to
power he raised the number of justices
on the Constitutional Court from 11 to
15 thereby appointing four of his own
judges he then lowered the compulsory
retirement age for judges and
prosecutors freeing up hundreds of posts
for candidates loyal to the party so
having all your party sympathizers in
such key judicial positions is hardly a
guarantee of impartiality is it first of
all the second thing you mentioned the
pension age that has been redrawn it has
not been in effect and raising the
number of judges in the Constitutional
Court was simply a reaction to the
number of cases before the
Constitutional Court those those
appointments are not by the way not by
the Prime Minister but they are by
Parliament and they are not for life so
there is obviously a normal functioning
of judges being on a Constitutional
Court and then the Parliament nominating
new ones so nothing really changed just
because the number was increased missed
a hit vaguely just a guarantee complete
control your party set up a national
judiciary office run by Sunday hand
who just happened to be a student
contemporary of mr. Albans and the way
it was set up made it impossible for
Parliament to sacker
she's been unassailable for her
nine-year term hasn't she with power of
this kind owned by your party the
justice system is almost guaranteed to
be biased in your favor isn't it not at
all she's no longer by the way a leader
of that organization
she's now a member of the Constitutional
Court and they're reliably debates
within the judicial system there is
another body there the the Judicial
Council and they have had lively debates
over the past couple of years and that's
right that way there's no problem with
that at all just another illustration
that the system works we have debates
and then there are outcomes that are
results of lively debate yes but she was
in a position where she could veto
judicial promotions and even influence
which judges heard which cases that's a
lot of power that's vested in your job
like in a number of them just like just
like in a number of other EU member
states that can happen there are n EU
member states where is the Minister of
Justice who makes those appointments
there are countries that don't even have
a public prosecutor there are countries
that where there is no formal
Constitutional Court there are different
constitutional identities and systems
within the European Union they are all
democratic just the fact that they are
different does not mean that they are
undemocratic there are different ways to
organize the judicial system well when
you are having the hallways you having a
hard time convincing people in the rest
of Europe about your democratic
credentials
let's look if we may add to that other
democratic feature that you prize
elections which you talked about after
2010 your party wasted no time in
redrawing the electoral map in Hungary
changed constituency boundaries to favor
your own supporters and riding roughshod
over objections in other words
gerrymandering was rife wasn't it
it wasn't the system was made thinner we
have reduced the number of members of
parliament from
for 382 to just 199 we have streamlined
the electoral system there was no
gerrymandering and in fact if you look
at the the latest local elections for
four townships the opposition one
important positions for instance mayor
of Budapest was taken over the post of
mayor of Budapest was taken over by the
opposition as well as they want a number
of other countries and municipalities
there is again a well-functioning
democratic system both the OEC II the
United Nations observers and others
confirm that there is no democratic
problem with the Hungarian electoral
system and there was no gerrymandering
and let me go back to your point that
you mentioned in your question you said
we had difficulty convincing our
European partners I think you said about
Hungarian democracy on the contrary it's
our political opponents that don't want
to accept that there can be a government
a conservative Christian democratic
government that is strong that is
decisive and successful let's talk in
the brief time we have left about your
country's treatment of migrants you've
made it perfectly clear you don't want
them in Hungary you've refused routinely
to take them in and share the burden
with the rest of the EU and now you've
been found to be in breach of EU law
earlier this month the European Court of
Justice found your detention of asylum
seekers on the borders with Serbia to
have been illegal it's a damning
indictment of Hungary's treatment of
asylum seekers isn't there there is a
debate right now and it's partly a legal
debate and it's a debate about European
law and Asylum law you mentioned this
verdict of the European Court of Justice
I mentioned other one just a few months
ago that of the European Court of Human
Rights in Strasbourg and linked to the
Council of Europe they also looked at a
very similar case about the transit zone
and how migrants or asylum seekers are
treated by Hungary and they found that
the transit zone
in Hungary and the border of Hungary was
not detention at all since it is open
towards Serbia in that particular case
and not not closed well that's why the
European you say that but the European
Court of Justice mister his vague in the
European Court of Justice said you
detained two families seeking asylum in
a border transit zone for more than a
year giving them no opportunity to have
their detention reviewed by a court and
with no opportunity to lawfully leave
that zone of their free will in any
direction
how does illegal detention fit in with
your much trumpeted views about
protecting Europe's Christian heritage
what's Christian about that sort of
behavior let me be very quick they are
not deterred not detained they can leave
that transit zone whenever they want
towards Serbia from where they came from
these families I think Christian
responsibility means that you help
people where they are you take help
where help is needed instead of bringing
the problem into the European Union that
is unable to deal with hundreds of
thousands or millions of migrants coming
into this continent that's not the way
forward the past five years have shown
very clearly that's that's an
interesting excuse that's an interesting
excuse mistake vaguely but I'm asking
which one which Bible teachings which
Bible teachings sanction forced and
illegal detention of travelers and
migrants who have nothing there is no
force and and there's no foreigner
there's no forced detention at Hungary's
borders those who come and stay in the
transit zone can at anytime that they
wish go back and leave from where they
came from it is not it is not a
detention Europe can only deal with the
hundreds of thousands of people in need
in the Middle East in Africa elsewhere
in Asia if it brings together pulls
together its strength and takes help to
those regions in need it's not the
interest of those regions that they that
they lose their most you
best people that can work and that could
have those territories to develop you
alright take help to those areas there
instead of instead of legalizing illegal
entry into either hungry or anywhere
else all right here's the Union that's
what the last word and it's not
supported by the European people bullish
it vague II we're out of time thank you
very much for being on conflict zone
thank you very much indeed
[Music]
you
[Music]